[Music]
spider-man's back in the MCU people it's
happening guys it's official last time I
was I was on movie talk yesterday last
time I was on movie talk I was like not
still public negotiations it's still
definitely public negotiations it's
weird when I learned the news this
morning I was happy I was excited I was
also like yeah pretty much I did not
experience a surprise state I was just
like oh this soon huh yeah yeah yeah I
mean there's a lot to cover here
apparently Kevin Feige isn't too busy to
produce another spider-man film like how
the person that Sony said is apparently
not too busy to do another Star Wars
movie you say whatever now like
especially when it comes to negotiations
and things like these I feel like
they'll just say anything that's the
public all of them Tom Holland included
yeah everyone's just saying what they
gotta say in the meantime so variety
broke this news and then the first bit
of story is Marvel and Disney will
receive a roughly 25 percent of the
profit which is good negotiation you
know they said we want 50 we want 50
percent and then what you always do is
you aim high so that way they meet you
somewhere in the middle does this mean
they're going to fund to 25% of this
movie and now there's no co-financing
which is smart because that still gives
Sony ownership over spider-man I mean
the merchandise deal still stands with
Marvel as far as from what I understand
but in terms of the movie property
themselves they still belong to Sony
this is no no official update or word
necessarily on this is mean spider-man
can cross into venom not because there's
a quote by fie you would send a very
interesting to me he said I am thrilled
that spider-man's journey in the MCU
will continue to I and all of us at
Marvel Studios are very excited that we
get to keep working on it spider-man is
a powerful icon and hero whose story
crosses all ages and audiences across
the globe he also happens to be the only
hero with the super power to cross
cinematic universes so a Sony continues
to develop their own Spidey bursts you
never know what surprises
the future might hold because there was
that talk early on when this news was
first breaking about how Marvel wanted
to say in the extended version because
this deal is nowhere near as long as the
initial deal when they first got
spider-man the deal is only for one more
spider-man film and one more appearance
in a Marvel phase four movie so that's
what they got sold so far so it's like a
short-term deal a short-term negotiate
its not to wreck everything we just so
it kind of makes you go is it a short
deal because they want to be able to
conclude the home trilogy make a home
landing trilogy you know is that what
they're trying to do or is it to you
know figure this longer deal out over
the next couple years because I already
have a release date in mind for this
which I thought was pretty cool my July
16 2021 that's one day after Wizards of
Waverly Place is David Henry's birthday
yeah so he's gonna have a great birthday
they definitely already have their
spider-man 3 movie in mind and either
way this is good I think this is good
for us on the audience perspective of
things I think they might probably
conclude it in a in a way where it could
be a little open-ended depending on you
know how negotiations go over the next
couple years actually next like you yeah
and a half because I still got a film
and put it in post on all these things
so depending on how negotiations go I
imagine a price and in a way where this
could be the ending of it or now that
we've figured out a deal and we're gonna
keep spider-man around even longer okay
yeah I guess I would be kind of
surprised if yes some of their
subsequent deals can come out of this
because I think the main message of this
whole debacle has been you opened that
door and put spider-man into the greater
MCU and I don't think anyone's ever
going to go quietly and to just like
well we got our third movie and Sony
just take it back down don't ever
imagine that the outcry of fans has been
so loud and I'm sure the message to both
Sony and Marvel has become very clear
that people want these characters
together see I would not at all be
surprised if there was a subsequent deal
and we and weirdly
I don't remember which site it was but
one of the headlines I was reading said
that basically it insinuated based on
this quote perhaps that they're going to
see spider-man in their own Sony movies
too because yeah you have Morbius and
venom and also I mean I now I'm just
speculating but because you have so many
characters scattered across so many
things this could potentially help
because there are other characters like
Ghost Rider and stuff
who have like team-up potentials with
characters like Morbius sure that you
know could become possible like I feel
like this Spider Man thing is a linchpin
to potentially broadening out the
universe if they can just figure out
that money it's like the money is is the
one thing that seems to be holding
everything up well I don't think Marvel
and Sony can come to an agreement on Tom
Holland crossing over into there like
let's say that Tom Hall I can still be
in the MCU
I don't think Marvel will agree to
allowing Tom Holland across into the
other spider-verse films like venom
Morbius Madame web yeah into any of
those characters unless they can get a
say in those extended spider-verse
movies as well because they really do
care about consistency with their
characters and making sure whatever they
do with the character of the Tom Holland
portrayal in the spider-verse doesn't
mess with the continuation they put in
their MCU movies so that's why I think
when all this started initially breaking
a while ago that they were pursuing to
try to get to control a little bit of
say or control over the extended
spider-verse conundrum but yeah I mean
this is exciting news this is cool it's
what we expected I think either way it's
good because I think it would be wise to
make like their spider-man trilogy
within the MCU and then he's gonna do
whatever appearance in another Marvel
movie I'm pretty sure the word is that
he is going to be the new lead in the
black panther 2 movie and potentially
crossover and steal the show in the
shang-chi movie yeah definitely he's
just gonna jump into all those new yes
anything with an ethnically diverse cast
non-white hohenhauser you got to put Tom
Holland in there's not enough white
actors in this because Disney is showing
how progressive they are and I agree
with these statements but you still need
a white guy
to eat it all but yeah I mean there's
like other spider-man news that I've
been hearing about Madame web movie
Cassandra Webb
I barely remember I think she was in the
animated series at one point like I saw
an image I'm like I've seen this
character in motion before as it reports
here usually depicted as an elderly
blind woman suffering from a chronic
near a mask you lured Aziz and makes it
difficult to move and breathe and as
such she's connected to a life-support
system that looks like a spiderweb a
clairvoyant character precognitive
abilities and once helps spider-man find
a kidnap victim that comes off the heels
of a Collider exclusive report but I
think Jeffrey Snyder that I found this
morning when I was gathering info on
this story and you know I got the morbid
morbus the morbid movie and the Morbius
movie coming up they got the venom 2
movie slowing in into production I see
what you did so they got a lot of things
going on with spider-man but the good
news is is that you know spider-man is
back in the MCU I don't know every would
like what would be your main theory here
though do you think they're prepping to
extend negotiations and make the other
things I wanted to sort out you know yes
yes I think that's what their game I
feel like they needed some kind of fix
to avert crisis in the nearest nearest
future because I'm sure that even though
there's not a spider-man movie announced
for phase 4 or whatever you know they
still probably had spider-man related
plans you saw the 2021 movie would be
face forward in it lasts like three
years I don't have a great indicator for
what marks of Phase I just know that it
wasn't listed on there phase four chart
at comic-con so I feel like to avert
immediate crisis yeah they needed to
come up with some kind of deal that
works in the interim that addresses the
stuff that happens in that post credits
scene from spider-man far from home that
clearly indicates the story's not done
and then yeah I think this is just kind
of to buy time to work out a more long
term any more substantial deal for
spider-man
mn I mean Amy Pascal Kathleen Kennedy
and Amy Pascal the two most respected
female producers in Hollywood a variety
of reports Pascal was equally a fork in
her statement this is terrific Peter
Parker story took a dramatic turn and
far from home and I could not be happier
we will all be working together as we
see where his journey goes
basically I am freakin relieved because
that cliffhanger who oh man put us in
quite a conundrum if they didn't have
such a cliffhanger I don't think they
would have been as freaked out about to
handle this and see CEO for Sony said we
have had a great collaboration over the
last four years and our mutual desire to
continue was equal to that of the many
fans we are delighted to be moving
forward together I'm waiting for the
president of Sony Pictures yeah it was
like configured it into all the work why
here his statement no I don't know what
he has is they about yeah what am i guys
too relieved about the news were you
glad that Spiderman might just be able
to continue in Sony and be like oh we
don't the worry about all these MCU
references or are you you know relieved
that he's finally back comment below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell you could
check us out on patreon where we do
weekly Q&A s TV show reactions stream
along store many shows sync up some
shows have reaction highlights included
so you don't have to worry about that
and he does music video coverage weekly